so we've been planning a backyard
barbecue
that's actually more than a backyard
barbecue and it's for
vernon winfrey appreciate today oprah
winfrey surprises her ailing father
vernon with a special barbecue and you
know lady o knows how to throw a party
who me the media mogul threw her dad a
fourth of july gathering with his
closest family and friends to honor him
in his hometown of nashville sharing
this video filmed by her bestie gayle
king it's for
[Music]
and so we wanted to be able to have all
of his friends come
and celebrate him while he was able to
receive the joy vernon had no idea about
the party and you know oprah is no
stranger to surprises
[Applause]
and this one seemingly went off without
a
he doesn't hitch know that this is for
him because he thinks it's uh he thinks
it's a fourth of july thing he doesn't
know that it's happening so he's gonna
walk out and see bernie appreciate he's
gonna walk out and see him i love him
oprah and gail also gave a tour of the
party and the food so we got
fried chicken over here with turkey we
got
burgers and hamburgers and all that
brisket you know o's gonna have the best
of the best when it comes to the grub
yes
check out the guest of honor sitting in
a special chair surrounded by his loved
ones
my dad's a barber so he put him in the
barbecue
there he is in the barber chair along
with the post oprah shared a special
message for her pops giving my father
his flowers while he's still well enough
to smell them vernon's bash comes nearly
a year after the release of oprah's own
special honoring our king celebrating
black fatherhood where she paid tribute
to many black dads including her own my
own life changed when i went to live
with my dad
vernon winfrey now my dad he was strict
yeah
he had some high expectations i know for
sure
that i would not have had the life that
i now have
be the person that i am
uh had i not spent that time with him as
a teenager and when e.t spoke to lady oh
ahead of the premiere she made it clear
she's got nothing but gratitude for the
man who raised her i wanted to elevate
lift up show the other side
of the narrative that we always hear
about black fathers not participating in
their kids lives and black fathers not
not being there i am the product of a
black father had my father not stepped
in and taken responsibility for me i
certainly wouldn't be sitting here
talking to you on on e.t or have the
life that i had and so i wanted the rest
of the world to see that to know that to
hear it feel it and have fathers
validated black fathers validated
[Music]